哈喽 我是想在零
现在呢 我是素颜
用的是原像机来拍摄
你们可以看到作为一个游动机来说
我现在的皮膚还是蛮好的
这个是我以前的皮膚
我是长了九年的豆豆和皮口
今天我要给你们分享一个宝木极的
去皮口供绿
我觉得我还是挺有资格来跟你们说
去皮口去
还是挺的
不是纸上谈冥
如果你们想知道游道机如何
正确的护服变成
灯磨一样的素颜
可以关注我
那去皮口不只是我用这个效果
这些都是我的粉丝宝帮丢的散块
去皮口治疗又只本的方法
我现在资资细起来交给你们
好听哦
现在呢 脸上已经有一堆豆豆和皮口的宝宝
你们听我的先取真心
零米擦护服品擦一样
剑效快多了
擦护服品擦要想把豆豆皮口擦美
时间快很长
而且呢
你不确定你是一周
还是一个月能够把他们擦美
真心是历感建议的
有一些宝宝一听到真心就很害怕
什么傷害皮膚之类的
但是真心他对皮膚的伤害
跟你掌豆豆流
都应都亏相比真的不算什么
你去找专业的人
给你清脸都应得不怎么会了
躺在呢
一个小时不到的脸就平整了
而且呢真心他还花不了什么钱
现在我要跟你们说
真心之后如何
互理让你们不再掌豆豆和皮口
有一些宝宝真心回来
或说要修户
擦一堆后重又有你的修户面双
忽待脸上
那我那我那我你这样
一周不到又要去真心了
心的豆豆和皮口又被你嫩出来了
我们在真心当晚呢
是可以正常的目于洗头洗脸擦户服平的
在真心晚前三天擦一些清爽
不门豆的修户产品
户完复了呢
再擦一个这样的豆豆药
给伤口消耗门
像我之前分享过的这一套
或者你用这个修户精华
搭配任何的
修户面双都可以
他们都很适合真心晚了之后用
特别是他
他的弹化都应得效果很不错
或者是用你手的上有的
你确定他们不会门豆门闭口的修户产品
也可以
咱们皮膚的自我修户能力就很强了
对付真心这些小伤口完全没问题
在第二件的时候呢
有一些清过的地方会长一些小龙包
你用一个真消毒之后呢
把这个龙包撤破
把龙几出来
几到没有血出现透明的组织业的时候就可以了
之后再擦一个豆豆药
真心晚这三天
不要化妆
不要擦防晒双
做好防晒
不要使用酸类模杀类
或者是去脚之类的护服平
也不要负面模让皮膚保持干爽
更有利于伤口的恢复
三天之后呢
当我们伤口已经恢复好了
就可以在护服平面加些酸类的护服平了
有动机是一定要学会用酸的
我们长一口就这么几个原因
出药太猛了
脚之层太厚了
油脂不能顺利的出来
堵在一面
就形成闭口了
之前去真心是治标
你用酸就是治本
加速皮膚的心成戴线
脚至没那么厚老毛口疏痛了
闭口就不那么容易长了
两看起来呢
也会很平滑
有光折
我建议用酸小白可以
是酸类的动模
这个动模我就是说过很多次了
它是我用我的酸类
很温和还很管用的一款
我上面从来没有用过酸的剪类用
它也很OK
農度低所以不会觉得自己
我很多粉丝宝宝也用了
我目前还没有收到
说用了它翻车的反馈
而且跟这上面飘的
这个日期来使用呢
也不怕忘记
所以我建议新手宝宝是一系这个
那怎么用呢
这一篇视频率连说得很详细了
那最后呢
我在分享一个我的绝杀
就是我的家庭版海肥秀
这是一个周护里
一周做一次
你会从一个必口心人变成一个水煮蛋
就是魔脸呢
你就感觉很平滑平镇
而且呢很柔软
长必口就是毛控里的油脂太多了
那我们在他还未行生必口
只是油脂的时候就定期的
把他们给清出来
那必口还怎么行成呢
都没有油脂给他行成了
你们可以去这个视频
下面看一下评论
我收到了无数的反馈
来跟我说他们的必口好了
现在的皮肤变成很平滑
细腻
那你们按照我说的一步一步来做
如果还长必口
你来找我我肯定回你
但你们先试一试
我说的这些方法
我相信你肯定会来感谢我的
那我们今天就到这里了
拜拜